[Music]
37 seconds of opening logos also why
isn't the Columbia girl holding a
neuralyzer so that she can erase the
audience's memory that they paid to see
this movie this arms Locker contains way
better weapons than any guard decides to
armed themselves with during a prison
break oh oh no but I have price just
killed and we were just getting to
appreciate his dry sense of humor after
having seen Boris kill a bunch of people
and now in possession of an extremely
dangerous weapon the guards decide not
to shoot Boris on sight when he comes
blasting through this door sorry darling
if she'd have been a Spice Girl eat the
same
okay so force is successfully broken out
of prison now how the hell does he plan
to get from the moon to the earth I'm
not even sure that's meat I think I just
saw tooth in that thing
Will Smith is a dick to falafel meat is
it a sin that Rip Torn isn't in this one
or is it more of a sin to break into
banks late at night while wasted
ladies and gentlemen Oscar winner Emma
Thompson Transformers Dark of the Moon
damn remember the 90s when wheel smith
said damn like that we all laugh is Jay
eating french fries in the Chinese
restaurant
that's a dining faux pas Sanchez Jersey
Members Only jacket the same spiky
projectiles that earlier blasted open
the very metal chains at the lunar max
prison can now be stopped by a door why
would the super-secret MIB transport
this large alien fish out in the open
like this does the driver have a
neuralyzer that he's just continually
firing off as he drives so that all the
people who see the alien will also
forget it also didn't Will Smith rip out
that fish's guts and kill it how is that
thing flapping around J suit is all wet
from the alien fish guts but by the time
he gets back to headquarters he's dry as
a bone this is a funny sight gag but the
character J is presented now in three
films would never hang this on his
bedroom wall for any reason at all dial
tone after hanging up cliche also Agent
J would probably not even be an agent
anymore without agent K and wouldn't
even remember agent a at all that's just
for starters
once again time-traveling movies only
affects one person that kid is a racist
why do we assume that the whole world
has changed but agent J doesn't get any
new memories J walks past this
interesting group of people but in the
next shot they're completely going on
who is it K I mean who is he to you know
you didn't you clearly asked who was K
like you didn't know who he was talking
about see the prerequisite for a joke is
that it'd be funny
clearly advice the screenwriters did not
take themselves temporal fracture
headaches I might accept this
explanation for agent J being the only
person who can remember the old world
but that would be all too convenient
that wouldn't it
why would Wurst go back to 1969 kill
agent K and then wait 43 years to attack
earth
why wouldn't borscht just go ahead and
kill this guy and keep time-travel away
from anyone else who might want to use
it you know in case someone wanted to go
back and prevent him from changing the
timeline okay what is this remember the
other timeline I want to know when and
where you sent him dude you know where
even if he decided to vacation in Cancun
for two weeks the guy went to Cape
Canaveral in July 1969 and killed
this log of Boris's time-travel
activities should not exist now the
forest as time traveled in change
history also jeffrey keeps a sensitive
logbook out in the open on his counter
for what reason again a little blip on
the historical radar oh that's a big
again how do you know eleven other
people in aliens went back in time and
nothing else has changed at all one guy
went back to 1565 to what kill the one
year old William Shakespeare and I mean
really high well not really
this asshole a Co Bradley he jumped off
Penn Station Will Smith disappears
completely in this angle we should at
least be able to see his shoulder 1969
wasn't the best time for your people I'm
just saying it's like a lot cooler now
well unless you're wearing a hoodie in
Florida why would the time travel device
return him to the top of the Chrysler
Building like what would happen if he
had jumped to a time that had no
Chrysler Building with a divisive
deposited him several hundred feet in
the air to free fall to his death Necco
wafers why does Boris even stop here so
that extremely cliched characters from
1969 can admire his bike and get freaked
out when he laughs no sunglasses in this
shop but agent Jay finds a way to put
sunglasses on before the neuralyzer goes
off in this show standard-issue
neuralyzer remember that why wouldn't
they did you just tell them that's what
it was
do they only remember what you instruct
them to remember and that's when I met
up wasn't Kay married before I mean it's
not unusual to fall in love with someone
else or anything but does his wife exist
he must deploy the arc net as he did
before there's no other way oh so this
is the one thing that has to go exactly
the same agent Jay in the future Boris
had probably caused so many changes in
the future by now but who gives it why
didn't he just do this with the original
MPs that found him and save some time
just going on my own experience with old
TVs that goldfish has got to be boiling
see why I recruited you you're good man
you didn't recruit him last time because
he was a good man you recruited him
because he ran down a cephalopod on foot
Morris throws agent Jake to the one spot
where he won't die like literally a few
feet in any other direction and Jay is
dead and Boris can win wait one a time
traveled back a few seconds earlier but
then there's no other versions of
themselves up here doing the fight from
a few seconds earlier why doesn't Boris
also remember that he just went back in
time and realize he needs to change the
attack pattern from before this thing is
just gonna stay right here throughout
all the vibrations of a fing rocket
launch
I guess it is I know a top secret
organization that can use a man like you
are you kidding me all this guy did was
let you into the rocket like that's
that's it and it was like really
criminal of him to do it so what exactly
do you see in this guy
what did James's dad participate in take
your kid to work day on the day of the
Apollo 11 mission seems like a dangerous
area to keep your kid during a rocket
launch especially in a hot car on the
beach who has he been watching this kid
how the fuck is he able to hear this
conversation from so far away the ocean
is loud you know helpful guy from the
past turns out to be the father of the
main character from the future cliche oh
come on seriously agent Kate didn't know
anything about James until he tracked
down an alien on foot in the first men
in black now we're supposed to believe
that he knew about him all along and
don't give me any of that it's because
the space-time continuum book because
remember Jeffries words you were there
so this is the way it originally
happened really I just want to say thank
you yes thank you for erasing every
memory I ever had of my father also
sci-fi comedy action film turns into a
big Nicholas Sparks movie at the end is
my new favorite moment in human history
at the end of the film heroes HBO again
[Music]
you complete
these aren't the droids you're looking
for he's heart Detroit's were lucky